wenn der tod von moritz und seinem
freund finn hat für viele fragen gesorgt
für viele stürzen im ganzen land
mittlerweile geht man davon aus dass die
beiden freunde aufgrund von drogen
experimenten verstorben sind
heute hat der 16 jährige moritz seine
letzte ruhe gefunden unser bild reporter
kalkweiß mehr dazu bei einem sehr
emotionalen trauergottesdienst haben
sich familie und freunde von ihrem
moritz verabschiedet vor dem altar stand
ein bild moritz und direkt daneben seine
urne umrahmt von einem trauerkranz
seiner eltern peter und elke rund 100
menschen kamen zu diesem
trauergottesdienst der unter strengen
krone auf lang stattfinden musste nur 58
menschen hatten platz auf den bänken der
kirche denn es musste immer einen
mindestabstand von zwei metern
eingehalten werden ob wohl zu sicher
stühle aufgestellt wurden verfolgten
viele den traugottesdienst vor den toren
der kirche unter den trauernden waren
viele kameraden von der freiwilligen
feuerwehr nordendorf dort wo moritz
mitglied war zu beginn des
traugottesdienstes liegt das lied
seasons in the sun es handelt von einem
sterbenden mann der letzte grußworte an
die menschen schickt die ihn auf seinem
lebensweg begleitet haben
moritz urne wurde dann in der vorletzten
reihe des friedhofes beigesetzt